welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition this is a dimension
as vast as space and as timeless as
infinity it is the middle ground between
not seeing the show and seeing it it is
the channel where we explain it so you
don't have to this is the twilight zone
the show has just dropped it's 6 episode
in the Jordan Peele reboot and six
degrees of freedom follows a group of
stranded astronauts that have to deal
with the fact that they are apparently
the last surviving members of the human
race throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the episode and its ending
as well as what I took from it this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen it yet then I highly recommend that
you turn off now without the way huge
thank you for clicking the video now
let's dive into my ending explain
breakdown of six degrees of freedom now
the first thing that really stood out to
me about this episode is that it's quite
similar premise wise to the original
Twilight Zone episode 5 characters in
search of an exit that episode follows 5
apparent strangers who find themselves
trapped inside a large metal cylinder
and throughout the episode they attempt
to offer up theories on how they got to
be in that position as well as
attempting to escape this to me at least
is a similar position to the characters
in 6° who are all headed towards a
destination though they do not know what
awaits them the group must work together
as one in order to escape the scenario
and this is mirrored in both episodes
eventually in five characters due to
teamwork they managed to escape and it's
revealed that they are in fact unwanted
toys that wish to be loved once more
this episode is quite jarring and it's
not one of my favorites from the
original series so I was actually quite
hopeful that this would be the one time
that Peele would actually best the
source material with one of his remakes
so how does six degrees of freedom hold
up well unlike the rest of the episodes
in the series six degrees has a rather
hopeful ending and despite the constant
nihilism that
in the storyline we follow the first
manned mission to Mars as they set out
to colonize the rest of the galaxy and
now they are initially humanity's bold
new leap into the Stars they quickly
become its last hope as the rest of the
planets population is wiped out due to
nuclear war similar to the prior
episodes in the season there is a clear
fear of other countries and the threat
of self-destruction looms heavily over
the plot whilst in a traveler the threat
came in the form of Russia Hiro is
betrayed it's North Korea were the first
to launch the missiles North Korea of
course has a lot of tension with the
u.s. right now and whilst a traveler was
rather heavy-handed in its social
commentary six degrees at least subtly
showcases that this could be a very real
scenario should tensions continue to
rise six degrees offers a commentary on
how humans are destined to either
destroy each other or to learn to
coexist peacefully and is back and forth
tension axes the episodes main motif
just in the same way that North Korea
ended up turning on the rest of the
world the humans trapped on the ship to
face these same challenges the greatest
danger for them is each other and the
episode teases what would happen should
the characters turn on one another out
of fear whilst it would be cliche for
the crew to eventually devolve into
harming one another six degrees actually
showcases what can happen if they work
together several of the characters often
become opposites of one another but they
learn to help each other in order to
reach a positive outcome though the
characters do make it to their
destination without turning on each
other
there are several real events that
happen aboard the craft that could be
seen as metaphors for real-world
problems
the main standout for me comes in the
form of a worry over an unplanned
pregnancy which makes some of the crew
members fear that if a child is born and
then their rations will be heavily
depleted this support Ares the subtext
of overpopulation worries that currently
exist on the planet and how many people
fear that if humanity continues to grow
in the way that there has been then it
will put the rest of the planet
danger however the humans still managed
to work together and make the best out
of a bad situation
and none of the characters give in to
that dr. Zaius though they irritate one
another they put these differences to
one side in order to push forward this
is definitely a positive message that
can be taken into the world and how many
of us felt helped when we saw Trump and
Kim jong-un actually working together
and meeting in order to try and have a
positive outcome to their disagreements
in the end this is what wins them favor
with their overseers the mysterious race
of aliens that has been watching them
throughout the episode the crew have
actually been in a simulation that the
creatures created in order to see
whether we as a race were worth reaching
out to and contacting this group has
been closely studying the humans and
carrying our observations to see if we
are worth saving which we prove
ourselves to be this is something that I
definitely believe about humanity and
whilst there is a lot of bad in us we
also have the potential to do great
things that will have an amazing impact
on the world and even the galaxy once we
eventually managed to venture into it we
are worthy of salvation and even though
it only came when we were forced to face
our own destruction we still did it
so while my thoughts on six degrees of
freedom well after a very disappointing
series I actually really enjoyed this
one I found the social commentary to be
subtle and unlike the other episodes
this was more focused on character
development of plot rather than the
message behind it though it's not
perfect at the rest of the season being
like this then I would have greatly
enjoyed it rather than feeling slightly
dismayed by the entire thing this
showcases the best in humanity whereas
the rest of the season puts forth the
worst and for me that's enough to make
it stand out from the others it
definitely bests five characters and
overall feels like a step in the right
direction for the show obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
episode and if you're enjoying the
series or not comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the entire season
thus far which would be linked in a
playlist at the end this is the channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]